good morning John I'm here in beautiful
Anaheim California ouch can't see out
the window cuz it's very late I'm here
for VidCon but I'm gonna do all the
people who aren't at VidCon a favor and
not talk about VidCon is that okay
here's the situation I don't like flying
I don't like when somebody tells me when
I can and cannot go to the bathroom I
get nosebleeds get slightly airsick and
don't like being away from the internet
and playing smells kind of funny I end
up doing it a lot anyway and I kind of
feel like I'm getting pretty good at it
so maybe there's some wisdom that I can
impart to the world so without further
ado here are my seventeen tips to make
your travel day less terrible don't try
and pack everything you might ever
possibly need make some hard decisions
I'm going on a three week long trip and
this is my bag now I know I don't care
that much about the this and yeah I only
own one pair of shoes but if I could get
it into that then you can get it into
one bag and that's just gonna make you
like way easier you're not your best
self on travel days you're gonna be a
little bit tired maybe stupid cranky you
might smell kind of bad that's fine you
have permission to be that way but also
give everybody else permission to be
that way as well liquids and gels go
into this thing if they don't fit into
this thing then you can't bring them
through security peanut butter counts as
a gel I learned this the hard way
nowadays you got to take everything out
of your pockets when you go through
security if you have like a tiny piece
of paper in your pocket then the guy at
the security will be like sir what's in
your pocket and you'll be like well on
the scanner it probably looks like a
tiny piece of paper but in fact it is a
rocket launcher leads me to don't be
mean to security people even though it's
fun to joke about because they don't
make the rules and they do get fired
if they don't enforce them but also
don't joke with them about your pocket
rocket launcher unless you want to eat
the carpet if you wear a hoodie you will
be pulled aside for further screening
this is not profiling there's just a lot
of room in that thing to hide stuff if
you don't have a big carry-on you don't
need to get on and make sure that it
finds a space just chill at the gate you
don't need to get in that big long line
you don't got a jostle for position you
have an assigned seat you're gonna get
there eventually and it's gonna be less
comfortable than the one you're in right
now so just chill until it's like final
boarding and then you just walk on the
plane
loving okay so you're boarding the plane
get out of the aisle this is one artery
and if you're clogging it everyone's
dying you may notice that the people in
first-class look unhappy and this may
seem odd to you because you're like but
they're the first-class people they got
the best seats on the plane but it turns
out that they got them by traveling like
200 days a year they don't pay extra for
those they're like the super VIPs
because they travel all the time and as
there's no way to live your life
depending on the airline you will get
various things for free during your
flight but you could only ever really
count on one of these of some sort and
maybe one of these which are these
little beasts Gogh cookies also cup of
soda water juice or coffee something
like that so maybe bring a snack also a
water bit Biddle a water bottle to fill
up after you've gone through security
because apparently past security is the
only place in the world where it's okay
to charge five dollars for a bottle lot
so you're not allowed to use electronics
during the take-off in the landing cuz
apparently the 50 millivolts from your
Kindle is gonna blow up a 747 or
something so bring a real book there
great anyway aren't they nice if you
have a connecting flight first thing you
do is you go to the board and see where
it is what time it is even if you're
like two hours late cuz that flight may
have been delayed - and you don't want
to miss it if you don't have to if you
do miss a connection while you're
waiting in line to get your stuff
rerouted you can be on kayak or Hipmunk
or whatever looking up to see what
flights you might get on or you can just
call the customer support cuz it's
better to be waiting in two lines if you
can do two at the same time you never
know which one's gonna fit it up first
this has helped me many a time I hope
this video helps you out next time you
go on a travel adventure John I will see
you on Tuesday
I think I'm gonna be see you before then
actually because he like literally on
the other side of that wall